mais l'est
la berceuse c'est le chant qui apaise
qui endort l'enfant de laponie ou du
maghreb d'italie du japon comme ici le
principe reste le même à charles doux
caler sur le rythme de la respiration
une rencontre entre l'enfant et sa mère
on pourrait dire que la berceuse c'est
un peu un patrimoine mondial parce que
effectivement c'est la transmission
orale de génération en génération depuis
sans doute la naissance des hommes et
des dieux revois je crois pas qu'il y
ait une culture où il n'est pas cette
pratique de berceuses ce qui est
intéressant dans les berceuses du monde
c'est que justement on n'a pas une
approche cognitive on a une approche du
coeur et du coup la proche du coeur elle
passe par par l'intention l'émotion la
vibration la musicalité et si on
comprend pas les mots ça n'a pas
vraiment d'importance
loulou toutes les chansons on peut les
chanter de toutes les façons possibles
failles l'anam n'a par exemple cette
chanson italienne qui fait file à nana
babines
c'est presque une chanson gay on peut la
chanter banana banana beach line là tout
de suite on est dans une autre énergie
le coup de coeur de l'académie charles
cros et bien sûr un coup de pouce pour
ce projet mené depuis plusieurs années
c'est aussi une vraie reconnaissance que
la chanteuse a encore du mal à risque ça
me dépasse ça donne une autre dimension
à ce travail j'ai réalisé un jour je me
suis dit mais il ya des enfants qui vont
grandir avec ça et un jour peut-être les
rencontrerai puis le diront c'est toi
qui m'a bercé toute mon enfance c'est
magique
enfin moi je ça me fait pleurer